TO WHY THEY WON’T LET
REPORTERS IN THERE AND WHY THEY
WON’T LET US GO IN THERE LET’S
BRING IN DAN BONGINO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR FORMER SECRET
SERVICE AGENT AND FORMER NYPD
OFFICER, HEY, DAN.
>> HOW ARE YOU GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: GOOD MORNING, WHAT’S
YOUR REACTION TO THAT?
>> WELL, I MEAN, HOW IS THIS
NOT INFURIATING, GUYS?
I MEAN, THIS IS A BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT, TED CRUZ IS A MEMBER
OF CONGRESS, MEMBER OF THE
UNITED STATES SENATE, AND
HE’S A DULY-ELECTED SENATOR.
HE REPRESENTS ONE OF THE LARGEST
STATES IN THE UNION, TEXAS.
HE’S DOWN THERE, TRYING TO, JUST
TAKE ON VIDEO TAPE FOR AMERICA
TO SEE WHAT’S HAPPENING AT THEIR
BORDER.
WE OWN THIS.
IT’S OUR COUNTRY.
IT’S NOT JOE BIDEN, OKAY IT’S
OURS.
ARE WE NOT ENTITLED TO SEE THIS
AND THINK OF THE
NONSENSE FROM THAT PRESS
PERSON OR  WHOEVER SHE WAS,
SHE’S A GOVERNMENT EMPLOYEE
WHICH IS SCARY YOUR TAX DOLLARS
ARE PAYING HER TO BLOCK A U.S.
SENATOR FROM SEEING WHAT’S
GOING ON.
SHE SAYS A COUPLE THINGS THERE
WHICH ARE SO ABSURD YOU’D THINK
LIBERALS BE LOSING THEIR MINDS
TOO.
SHE SAYS AT ONE POINT, THIS IS
NOT A ZOO.
WELL, I MEAN, THAT’S OBVIOUS
IT’S NOT A ZOO, BUT WHY ARE YOU
TREATING PEOPLE LIKE ANIMALS
THEN?
YOU HAVE THEM HEAD-TO- TOE
STACKED IN PLASTIC
BOXES YOU’RE WATCHING THE VIDEO
NOW GUYS I CAN SEE IT, AND WRAP
PED IN LITERALLY, NOT
FIGURATIVELY, WRAPPED IN LITERAL
EMERGENCY BLANKETS, AND YOU’RE
CLAIMING IT’S NOT A ZOO?
AGAIN, WHY ARE YOU TREATING
PEOPLE LIKE ANIMALS?
THIS IS THE GREAT IRONY OF THE
LEFT.
THEY ACCUSE YOU OF WHAT THEY DO
AND THEN THEY PUT THEMSELVES ON
THIS HIGHER MORAL ARC THAN YOU.
IT’S JUST RIDICULOUS.
THIS IS SERIOUSLY, LIKE OLD
SOVIET UNION-TYPE STUFF.
BRIAN:  YEAH I WAS JUST THINKING
EVERY NETWORK SHOULD BE JUST AS
OUTRAGED WHEN THEY OFFER
STOCK FOOTAGE OR  TO SEE ONE
SANITIZED FACILITY AS OPPOSED TO
THOSE.
CHRIS WALLACE DID A GREAT JOB
PRESSING YESTERDAY.
FORMER NYPD COP, I FIND THIS
UNBELIEVABLE.
NEW YORK IS ENDING QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY FOR POLICE.
ESSENTIALLY IF SOMEBODY YOU
ARREST OR  DETAIN DOESN’T LIKE
THE WAY YOU TREAT THEM, YOU
COULD BE SUED.
>> YEAH, I HAVE A THOUGHT ON
THIS.
YOU KNOW, CONGRESS HAS QUALIFIED
IMMUNITY TOO.
THEY CAN GO ON THE HOUSE FLOOR
AND SAY THINGS AND CAN’T BE
PROSECUTED TO SPUR OPEN DEBATE.
I SAY WE TAKE QUALIFIED IMMUNITY
AWAY FROM THEM.
THEN YOU’D SEE A REAL DEBATE
ABOUT QUALIFIED IMMUNITY.
BRIAN:  THIS IS DEVASTATING.
>> IT IS DEVASTATING HAVING
BEEN A POLICE OFFICER, BRIAN A
STRONG LIBERTARIAN STREAK AND
I’M ALL ABOUT ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
POLICE OFFICERS AND MOST
GOOD POLICE OFFICERS SUPPORT
THAT TOO.
WE ALREADY HAVE A, KNOW INTERNAL
AFFAIRS.
YOU HAVE THE CIVIL CIVILIAN
COMPLAINT REVIEW BOARD WHERE IF
YOU WANT TO FILE A COMPLAINT
AGAINST A COP AND YOU’RE TURNED
WAY THAT POLICE OFFICER CAN BE
FIRED FOR TURNING YOU AWAY.
NOW YOU WANT TO OPEN UP POLICE
OFFICERS IN THE COURSE OF THEIR
DUTIES HAVE TO ENGAGE IN ALL
KINDS OF BEHAVIOR NORMAL PEOPLE
DON’T.
FIST FIGHTS ON A DAILY BASIS FOR
PEOPLE WHO ATTACK POLICE
OFFICERS.
NOW YOU WANT TO OPEN THEM UP TO
LAWSUITS?
THIS REMINDS ME OF THOMAS SOUL
WHO ALWAYS SAYS LIBERALS NEVER
THINK OF SECOND ORDER EFFECTS
AND THEN WHAT?
WHAT’S GOING TO HAPPEN AFTER
THIS YOU’LL SEE A FERGUSON
EFFECT ON STEROIDS, GUARANTEED.
STEVE: OH, MAN OH, MAN ANOTHER
REASON WHY HE MOVED FROM NEW
YORK TO FLORIDA.
DAN BONGINO, THANK YOU VERY MUCH